all right i want to talk a little bit
about what's gone on the contrast
between what's going on in democrat
cities and what's going on in republican
cities right now
i saw this from the new york post and we
have two articles that are going to go
together on this um one is from the new
york post that showed footage
showing a flash mob of looters
ransacking a 7-eleven in los angeles
let's play some of this video for people
it's a street takeover
yeah
so what you're seeing here are robberies
that
happened during a street takeover it
says when drivers flooded and blocked a
city intersection with their vehicles
to create a pit in the middle of it and
then you also see they ransack the 711
they go in they actually wind up making
off with a handful of cigarette with
handfuls of cigarettes snacks and other
goods look at this
just look at this they just walk in look
at look at the destruction how
disgraceful
this is los angeles people can't imagine
why people left los angeles to come to
florida look at this
so i have two comments on this and you
can play this a little bit more if you
want tyler while i'm talking first of
all my initial reaction is who raises
these people
who raises these people you know how i
always talk and i uh go back to what
happens at the dinner table and what
happens at the home this is why
i guarantee you if you did studies on
the people who permit com you know uh
commit crimes like this you're going to
find problems at home you're going to
find absentee dads you're going to find
something going on in a large percentage
of cases here because when you have
accountability to parents and by the way
accountability to faith in many respects
no one talks about the role of faith in
this stuff but when you have
accountability
to something bigger than yourself you
don't behave this way there is a lot
that goes into the way people are aren't
raised look at this
i mean this is just disgusting well and
that was larry elder's take on this is
that uh this is 2017 recent estimates
show that about 40 of births in the
united states occur outside of marriage
meaning
potentially there's not a father in the
house that's right he's a single parent
and
this is what you get it's a leading
cause of destruction and community when
you don't have particularly a dad
you see so many fatherless homes when
you don't have that infrastructure in a
home when kids feel lost confused lonely
you then it bleeds out into their
education they get into trouble you you
see it manifest like this now what's
also interesting about los angeles is
this is in the new york post article
which i love that they highlighted the
incident comes as la county district
attorney george gascon and his office
have come under fire you don't say
for prosecutorial laxity that some blame
for a spike in the city's crime he has
been criticized for announcing plans to
soften the state's three strikes law
which mandates harsher penalties for
repeat offenders so what you have is
what you have going on in new york city
you have these very very liberal
district attorneys and they make it so
that criminals get away with murder
sometimes actually
they get away with severe crimes they
get away with small crimes they get away
with repeat crimes and they don't have
proper accountability so what's the
lesson there to someone who seeks to
inflict harm let's go to la and do it
they're not going to behave like that in
a place where they know that there are
harsher penalties for their behavior but
these these cities
these places we're going to cover a
couple more of them right now are
becoming enclaves for a crime and that
is why you saw so many people leave los
angeles and head
to places you know if they wanted a city
they were like i'm going to miami if
they would they were going anywhere else
but there because you cannot raise
children in an environment like that if
you have a family you also don't want to
have your business what if your business
is a few blocks from that business
you know what i'm saying it gets very
scary and it gets very dangerous if
you're living in any area where
criminals are getting a message
that there are no consequences or very
small consequences if any for their
actions forget it it's over
going along with that i know tyler's
googling something but going along with
that in the daily mail
they talked about something called the
death of downtown san francisco
cleveland and portland were pulled in
particular as seeing an activity drop by
almost 50 percent as soaring crime in
the democrat-run cities forces workers
tourists and homeowners away
people it's like abandoned you know when
you went to those abandoned towns that's
what it's turning into let's take a look
at this in a recent study by the
institute of governmental studies this
is at uc berkeley san francisco's
downtown area was found to be only 31
percent active over the spring of 2022
when compared to pre-print pre-pandemic
levels according to the latest fbi
unified crime report san francisco had
the highest overall crime rate of the 20
largest cities in the united states
recording
six
6917 crimes per 100 000 population can
you imagine look at these look at this
shooting up on the street disgusting how
are you going to walk past this stuff
with your with your kid in a stroller
you're not this looks like occupy wall
street these images that used to be in
uh downtown manhattan only it's like a
perpetual state of being in san
francisco
maybe it's nancy pelosi's district
san francisco mayor london breed by the
way demanded cities remember this
demanded cities defund the police last
year oh that worked out well london
announcing that the golden gate city
would be one of the first to do so and
promising to slice 120 million dollars
from the budgets of its police and
sheriff's department
so let's just connect the dots on policy
here you've got these liberal work da's
that send a message to criminals that
they're not going to be consequences for
their actions you've got defund the
police movements heavy in these areas
where people know that there are less
police on the streets so if they commit
a crime they're more than likely to not
be faced by someone else
with a gun to stop them because the only
people that have guns in these places
are the police
don't get me started on gun control
the city of san francisco by the way
according to this article fascinating
also green lit its first open air drug
market how nice in san francisco civic
center which spurred vagrants and
homeless encampments across the city to
use illegal substances out in broad
daylight
how nice
so now you're walking around there with
your family or you have a business and
that's what's going on on your front
door by the way that is happening in new
york city as well
um i got a call a few days ago about
that a friend of mine was like you
cannot believe the amount of just drugs
hardcore drugs being done in broad
daylight in manhattan right now i'm
going to new york next week i'm going to
be there for 12 hours it was the
shortest amount of time i could manage
to be there um let's just say i don't
miss the city
and i'm going to take a look around i'm
going to wander around a little bit and
see what's going on if i see anything
i'm going to report on it i'm going to
let you know
by the way people in san francisco um
just so you know if you're living there
and you're like living on cloud nine and
you're like no no no it's not so bad hmm
crime remains stubbornly high in the
golden gate city with overall crime up
7.4 as of august 14th assaults are up
nearly 12 percent robberies are up 2.4
thefts have spiked by 17.5 and rapes
have increased by 9.5 well if that's not
an invitation to move san francisco i
don't know what is styler if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]